На підборах, в капелюхі та обов’язково у світлому вбранні.
34-ти річна фермерка Катерина Скрильник займається тваринництвом у селі на Полтавщині.
Її стиль руйнує всі стереотипи щодо того, як виглядає жінка в корівнику або серед коней.
Я сама для себе створила ту зону комфорту, яка мені подобається. Мені подобаються і підбори, і сукні.
Моє головне гасло - бути не лише людиною, а залишитися ще й жінкою. Я тоді відчуваю в собі більше впевненості.
Катерина започаткувала свій бізнес - фермерське підприємство "Фортуна-2015" - шість років тому.
Необхідні знання спочатку отримала в рамках канадського проєкту про сучасні стандарти фермерства.
Вирізняє жінку не лише її стиль, а й любов до тварин.
Приміром, старих і хворих корів не позбувається, як це зазвичай роблять на селі, а лікує.
Чому ми лікуємо її? По-перше, вона вагітна. Для мене це не гуманно - здавати вагітну тварину на м’ясокомбінат. Треба хоча б дати можливість народити теля.
Нас навчили, що потрібно поліпшувати умови перебування тварин на фермі. Бо до цього нас ніхто не вчив. Тримаєш тварину, та й добре.
А нас навчили, що тварина - як дитя. Я ти до нього ставишся, стільки воно й буде віддавати продукції.
Катерина утримує понад 70 корів, овець та коней. Вона вміє і пологи прийняти, і полікувати, і корм підбирати, аби корови не хворіли.
Також навчилася тонкощам технології зберігання молока, аби воно було дійсно вищої якості.
За освітою жінка - інженер-механік. Як поводитися з тваринами, знає з дитинства.
А ще вона пройшла безліч усіляких курсів. Фермерством Катерина займається разом зі своїм чоловіком Владиславом.
У нас навіть акаунт один на двох у соцмережах.
У подружжя вже троє дітей - і це стало додатковим стимулом зайнятися фермерством - аби діти росли на природі і їм нічого не бракувало.
Катерина заснувала власне фермерське господарство з тваринництва. А Владислав займається рослинництвом.
У моєму я головний. А в її - вона. Усі питання ми вирішуємо разом і доходимо спільної згоди. У нас нема такого, що я скажу, що буде так, а вона так.
Засідаємо на консиліумі.
Катерина - двигун обох господарств, і Владислав це визнає. Бо у Катерини гарно виходить не лише тварин доглядати, а й вести бухгалтерією.
А ще - успішно подаватися на гранти підтримки фермерів. Саме завдяки цим програмам подружжю  вдалося розвинути свій бізнес.
Катерина зізнається, що гранти - справа клопітка і вимагає великого терпіння, наполегливості, а іноді й сміливості…
А що робити нам сільським підприємцям по 130-ій постанові, які вже взяли кредити в 2019 році? Чи буде продовжена ця програма? Чи буде компенсація?
Настілки хочеться підняти якість утримання тварин і умови праці працівників.
Ми не середній бізнес, ми для банків просто міні-сфера, вони в нас бачать дуже великий ризик.
Це ще дуже складно. І коли ти приходиш,  і на тебе дивляться з недовірою,
ще навіть ніхто не запитує, що, мовляв, дайте вашу фінансову звітність не за рік, а за 3 роки… Просто не хочуть тебе сприймати як бізнес.
Поряд з Катериною в Миргородському районі своє фермерське господарство має 43-річна Ірина Маслівець.
Займається рослинництвом. Вона, як і Катерина, знається на цьому, бо виросла в селі.
Своє господарство заснувала 10 років тому в часи, коли на селі майже нікому не платили гроші.
Ірина вважає фермерство ризикованою справою. Адже починала вона теж з ризику - взяла в оренду 3 гектари землі і посадила там кукурудзу.
Подружжю довелося усе робити вручну, бо ніякої техніки в них тоді не було.
Ми ті самі 3 гектари вручну виламуємо, складаємо в сарай, щоб висохло для зими. Завжди були субота-неділя базарні дні.
Ми брали 4 мішки кукурудзи, перемелювали, відбирали зерно, виходило з 4 мішків кукурудзи мішок зерна. Ми це зерно продавали.
Це були копійки. Було важко. Але головне - бажання, решта буде...
Але найважче було те, що її намагання стати фермеркою викликало неабиякий спротив у рідному селі.
Мала доводити мало не на екзамені, що має необхідні знання для заняття фермерством.
Я коли землю брала, мене гукнули в адміністрацію. Мені екзамен, тому що, як це? Жінка хоче взяти землю і фермерство відкрити?
Але ж жінка! Для людей, чоловіків це було дивно. І мені було важко…
Той чиновник через кілька років вибачився перед Іриною, бо своїми врожаями вона продемонструвала, що працює не гірше за чоловіків.
Нині вона орендує 170 гектарів, платить пайщикам доволі добру оренду, а на додачу ще пшеницю, кукурудзу, ячмінь, соняшник, олію і цукор.
Коли добрий врожай, жінка може дозволити собі платити пайщикам більше.
На тих на Полтавщині йде справжнє полювання, бо вільних земель уже немає.
Є різні. Є ті, що є підтримують. Є такі , що готові втоптати і чим скоріше, тим краще. У нас так.
Найдіть хорошу людину, дайте хорошу грошину - і пустить чутки. Все, більше нічого не треба.
Що, мовляв, банкрут, закривається, що там нічого не посіяно… Було багато чого…
Проте Ірина намагається на таке не зважати. Вона пишається, що сама може виконувати багато роботи, якої і не всі чоловіки вміють.
Я можу сісти на трактор, сіялку, можу налаштувати їх…
А ще Ірина може замінити свого чоловіка Віктора, коли треба терміново відремонтувати в полі техніку.
Міша, зачекай. Я ж кажу, що треба колесо прокрутити.
Комбайн кілька разів доводиться зупинятися, аби механізм не перегрівся через бур'яни. Чоловік Ірини Віктор нервує, а Ірина і виду не подає.
Якби не було затримок, ми б уже закінчили. Але нічого, дякую і на цьому.
Чоловіки Ірини та Катерини всіляко підтримують своїх жінок. Вони не вважають, що фермерство - це не жіноча справа.
У космос літали! Так що думаю, що тут не набагато складніше займатися землею, ніж у космос злітати.
У чоловіків є таке викривлене бачення, що це не жіноча справа. Але як показує практика, жінка нічим не поступається чоловікові.
Вони теж розумні,  здібні і можуть робити все, що завгодно. Аби було бажання займатися цим.
У Ірини, як і в Катерини, троє дітей. Донька Ольга в 11-тому класі. Усе літо разом з батьками на полі. Дівчина щиро захоплюється батьками.
Мої вчителі вважають, що фермери - це дуже дивовижні люди, які з якихось маленьких грошей піднімаються.
Вони дуже пишаються моєю мамою, яка з 1000 гривень, які в неї були, зробила отаке господарство.
Дівчина хоче продовжити справу батьків і збирається поступити в аграрний виш.
Жінок-фермерок в Україні поки ще небагато. Ірина з Катериною хотіли б, аби фермерок ставало дедалі більше.
Тваринництво - широка сфера діяльності, має широкі горизонти. Є корови, вівці, кози. Саме молочної продукції в Україні наразі замало.
І якщо ми хочемо мати здорове покоління, то нам потрібна молочна продукція.
Жінки, чоловіки! Хай піднімають сільське господарство! Молодь! Не треба кудись їхати. У кожного є земля! У нас були корови, свині.
Трактором чоловік мій косив, я гребла. Ми олійницю мали. Так, це пекельна праця, але ми ж хотіли жити і виживати.
Ірина та Катерина в різні роки ставали номінантками регіонального конкурсу "Успішна жінка року".
Вони є членами Асоціації фермерів України, намагаються впливати на політику держави щодо фермерів.
Катерина як депутатка сільради подала в обласну раду пропозиції щодо фінансової підтримки фермерів-тваринників,
оскільки в регіоні останнім часом тваринництво фактично зникає.
Жінки хочуть розвивати свої господарства й надалі. Катерина планує в майбутньому у своїх корівниках зробити свого роду
навчальний майданчик для студентів аграрних вишів - для охочих навчитися тваринництву.
Ірина хоче експериментувати з посівами - хоче піти проти правил і посадити просо, щоб зібрати два врожаї за рік.
Обидві більше розраховують на себе та своїх чоловіків, ніж на  державу.
Від держави хочуть лише, щоб закони щодо підтримки фермерства виконувалися і всі підприємці мали рівні умови.
З відкриттям ринку землі це стало ще більш актуальним.
Адже фермерки розуміють, що без доступу до пільгового кредитування їм буде важко купувати землі, якщо їхні пайщики зберуться їх продати.